tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo nuovo
video sono fa vj e non ci siamo tornati
su 8 del giorno mesto di merda l'ultima
volta perché siamo nudi nudi siamo nudi
nel mezzo dell'oceano che non ho capito
neanche come caso ci siamo arrivati ecco
infatti io ero rimasto qui ragazzi andrà
avanti perché non ho capito come cazzo
ci siamo
arrivo che è perfetto se già accaduto
pensiamo neanche partiti dall'unica cosa
perché questo si sta suicidando da solo
era stai calmo devo andare o no è che
cazzo ragazzi non ho capi mi sono
infiltrati in una nave non so come cazzo
ci sono entrato qui ed avverte che
salvataggio epico ragazzi mi stavo
cadendo in una maniera incredibile mi
sono salvato non sono anche come questa
un po al post ed è una cosa arma donna
quanti sono ragazzi la situazione si fa
drammatica se mette un piede male sono
nella merda ok ok ok perfetto no cazzo
non mi ha visto esso non mi ha visto
nessuno sono maschio pensò tra le casse
vai vai vai se rocchi il capitano mi
hanno visto c'è un polpo che cammina su
una cazzo di trave e voglio capire come
che non lo vedo non è possibile ma
ragazzi avete bevuto qualcosa va fatto
ok sono vivo sono vivo tenetemi oddio
anni per arrivare qui anni è stata una
cosa impossibile allora perché ci sono
delle banane qualcuno ha voglia di
spiegarmi che cosa cazzo situazione
perché se un va a perfetto deve essere
capitano ragazzi c'è il capitano nella
doccia e non lo disturba ma devo mettere
il cus conferme ed i tableaux che ne so
io lo trovo io mi sto vedendo non mi
stavo lecca pazzo e tu marinaio come
falsi rivolti avviamenti cosa quasi una
persona normale tu hai davanti il tuo
capitano e devi portarli rispetto se
oggi un'altra volta rivolgerti così a
meglio questa tela infilò perfetti già
capito il capitano è tornato però c'è
capitano perfetto ci sono ci sono
ragazzi siete in buone mani tranquilli
guido io tutto a tribordo tutto qui
non sto dicendo ma chi se ne fotte mai
così che cazzo ci fa mia moglie a prua
piloti amos tabarka come se non ci fosse
un domani era che hanno fate caso la
barca che si sta muovendo male non c'è
problema è tutto sotto controllo
altro che jack sparrow fece il casper
scassato qualcosa e non volevo ragazzi è
schiavi coltivata a lavorare io devo
andare incontrare una donzella chiesta
tizia che sta sulla mia barca sulla mia
donna che tu sei siamo entrambi in
pericolo e tu chi sei ma che il nonno
sono do marito domenico alla versione
perché non fare o dio c'è qua se la
donna c'è un fuoco ragazzi fate chi
ottiene a processo cazzo di coco mi deve
dare così fastidio ogni volta donna
allora facciamo così io lo uccido in
cambio della tua vah valigia da viaggio
amy che non starà girando in una maniera
incredibile di lancio questo cosa fa e
cosa fare ma brava mistrello due le
tette ragazzi il potere delle tette
funziona sempre un piano un piano che
non fallirà mai devo arrivare a cazzo
toglietevi scatole di merda allora gira
gira gira di sé
che culo avevo in mente sta cosa da
prima i ragazzi va il cazzo sui farming
fuoco sulla milia nave mio brava donna
perché gli ha tirato salvagente posso
chiederti un ballo è un polipo e un
cazzo di polipo non è poco se fai a
quello c'è ma perché mi ha tirato salute
non deve morire affogato mangiato dagli
squali e tutta e al figlio stazza ma è
inutile che tentò di darmi spiegazioni
perché non ha senso sono ancora sono
ancora qui sono ancora nell'acquario
ragazzi sono ancora io per cento
cosa è successo perché sto nuotando in
un acquario fatemi capire quanto sei
bello occhio detto e fatelo dire sono
cos'è uno squalo cell host la merda
c'è uno squalo che mi vuole infilare la
testa nel culo c'è anche riuscito
ragazzi vuole stuprarmi non ho capito
neanche perché non mi e siamo tornati
tutto sto bordello siamo tornati qui
perché fatemi capire perché non ce la
farò mai uscire pazzi abbiamo aspettato
più a lungo che potevamo brava bambina
brava bambina riconosci mib rava
cosa fai non toccare mia moglie
pervertito non toccare mia moglie oggi
ti ho già visto da qualche parte vecchio
amico di top di mio marito non andate
con lui non lo seguite non l'ho seguito
e non è malvagio ragazzi già possiamo
fare la hot del gioco di fare stai
tranquillo la mia famiglia non riesce a
riconoscermi semi ritmo io sono un cazzo
di polipo non anche ok ci siamo
sono uscito sono dio mio se vado a
riprendermi la mia famiglia
vado a riprendermela perchè il trattore
chiudere la sua ri uno strato rito
stronzo ce la farò perfetto non mi ha
visto ragazzi state tranquilli perché
non mi ha visto deve riuscire a uscire
come processi di qua tanta tanta tanta
tanta tanta ragazze state il
travestimento migliore nel mondo ha da
fare invidia solid snake tanta tanta
tanta tanta gente
nessuno nessuno ha notato la scatola
grossa più di loro
nessuno ha sospettato niente devo andare
a quel [ __ ] par di merda trovare la
mia famiglia ma farti capire se sono
ancora qui dentro che la quale ormai ha
chiuso madonna che cazzo voce cazzo è ma
perché dovete fare il trasloco proprio
quando dove infiltrarmi franchi di
ragazzi non c'è problema che ho tutto
sotto controllo
scavato in un cazzo di secondo nessuno
noterà un polipo che si aggira
nell'acquario ragazzi non so come cat è
perfetto stava andando tutto a buttare
non mi ha visto non mi ha visto ha avuto
l'allucinazione perfetto sai cos'è
[Musica]
polipo ninja ragazzino una normalità di
come cazzo si è possibile che non mi
abbiano visto devo tuffarmi devo
tuffarmi se perfetto ragazzi questa
questa è la tattica
abbiamo questo è un costume da squalo io
posso mettermi costume la scuola e
nessuno mi riconosce fatemi capire
perché devo riuscire ad andare di sopra
mi ha beccato mi ha beccato un tronco in
testa ma sono ancora vivo devo entrare
qua dentro non diventare due chiacchiere
al posto di prima il momento non vedo un
cazzo perché ciò costume contrario ma
marco metterlo dritto e l'abbiamo fare
perfetto il mio attraverso inventa
funzionato alla grande sono entrato solo
qualcuno ma va bene lo stesso non vedo
allora ridammi la mia famiglia lurido
pervertito cosa fai perché gli allegati
ero era un polipo vedi non ce la farei
mai a cominciano che sono un polipo non
ce la fai
perché loro non si credono ragazzini lui
è l'unico che capisce che sono un polipo
ma gli altri non lo fanno dove dietro è
uno è un tempo riporta ragazzino cosa ci
sta che cosa fa lei lei non aveva mai
creduto che io fossi un polipo questo
spiega molte cose cosa spiega cazzo ma
dio mi ammazzerà in casa tutti i giochi
non si sa che attaccherà un polipo cosa
fa no no no fermo scrivono madonan jato
che matrix altro che ma sei un pezzo di
merda ragazzi no perché hai detto la mia
famiglia che io sono un polipo non
dovevi dirglielo cazzo ma lo sai cosa mi
devo correre
sono un genio le banane le banane no
ragazzi le baruffe va bene possibile
io sono riuscito a passare sì bravo
figlio bravo figliolo corsi si fa così
ce l'ho fatta lo rivela mia moglie da
mia moglie camera a mano se ragazzi mia
moglie è fantastica fai un ponte per sé
un ponte di cosa che per vendo come non
detto
dobbiamo riuscire a cazzo agli 8 dove
arrivare alla fine come il caso cio tipo
dirà che sta crollando tutto la posso
fare
mamma mia che genio che già lo trovata
controllato la trave si professò cascato
giù come non detto ma non fa niente la
bambina andata bravi ragazzi la mia
famiglia è troppo è troppo forte
raga ma anche all'ultimo ce la posso
fare vai così di state of mind io dico
questo con di maneggiare coltelli contro
gli altri ma è così
siamo alla resa dei conti stronzo fuori
anche come ma muori cioè noi cosa così e
servino contattino fabbrica è successo
qualcosa non so cosa ma va bene così ma
ce l'abbiamo fatta
no no no no no cosa deve soffrire e
ringrazia che cosa fa perché lo sta
abbracciando dai perdonano cosa visto ha
rivelato la tua famiglia che sei un
polipo cosa che non si capiva perché non
stai abbracciare perché i ragazzi che
tentano di salvare sto tizio la mia
famiglia ti ama ma cosa l'annuncio non
ce l'ho più con te cosa m grazie al
cazzo stai per morire a cosa c'è di
peggio di immaginarsi che tuo marito è
un cazzo di polipo ragazzi basta vado io
non ce la faccio più impossibile se papà
è un polipo io e stessi da dove veniamo
questa è la domanda che mi pongo anch'io
da tantissimo tempo che cazzo di te come
ha chiarito
datemi la risposta però perché lo voglio
capire che cazzo ridono ragazzi
datevi una risposta seriamente essere
seriamente cosa cosa fanno
ma non può finire così 6 finisce così
ragazzi io voglio sapere da dove cazzo
vengono quei bambini non è possibile
perché sono nel cinema e posso andare
dove voglio ragazzi allora io voglio
sapere voglio assolutamente saper dove
credi di andare che il film non è finito
dove vai
metti mi piace al video prima metti il
gas ora che è stronzo se ne vanno tutti
i ragazzi è una cosa che devo
assolutamente sapere che il card questi
sono i titoli di coda più belli che io
abbia mai visto tra parentesi comunque
che cosa voglio sapere tanto che cazzo
arrivano quei bambini perché ridete
perché ridet ragazzi non ha senso tutto
questo non ha un po tutto senso
comunque ho finito 8 nei metri e scherzi
che è stata una cosa spettacolare
ragazzi io non so che altro dire sa
mettere le domande sul perché la gente
non ha capito che lui era un polipo
io non ho le risposte ai quindi ragazzi
io non so se cazzo dire di altro perché
mi sembra assurdo con che ragazze il
video vi è piaciuto come solito lasciate
un commento mi piace anche a faccia di
facebook e come ogni video trovate nella
descrizione a siena se dovrei scritti
scrive non ci vediamo al prossimo nido
belle ragazze
[Musica]